plus loin
ou non
Yo
bien
et les filles
ouvre-moi la porte
une semaine s'étire et une étape change
une bougie a été allumée et un chapeau
je vais courir moi et mon garçon
comment ça a été aujourd'hui
Dans mon quartier
où est-ce que je dis Dieu
où je vis, Dieu, une histoire d'amour avec
un autre sens là où je vis
Je vis
5 sur le balcon il y a un gars de dehors
quand un mec est sur le balcon
au balcon
fille, il y a un gars sur le balcon dans le
balcon
et ici
fille
ouvre-moi la porte
du bas bon bruit et un bisou maman
pour finir, la télévision s'allume et
le miroir qui répond y a l'air bien
des garçons qui
viens tôt, je suis mon histoire d'amour
Dans mon quartier
où j'habite
Les histoires d'amour
avec 22 autres personnes là où je vis
Je vis
sur le balcon il y a un gars de dehors
il a dit sur le balcon et c'était sur le balcon
regarde regarde il y a
de la fille de la loi
il y a un gars sur le balcon
et dans la maison de Rita un petit garçon sec
dit que personne ne le connaît mais elle l'a invité
ses amis la protègent et la protègent dans le
porte et maintenant viennent Bob et les rangers qui
il me touche
maintenant je vais
avec une sorte d'amour
regarde regarde regarde regarde regarde regarde
regarde le gars, hé regarde, regarde, c'était le cas
un gars de l'extérieur a blâmé
Rita se bat contre lui, la faute est Trenc SR
et je vais chercher du pain
une sorte d'amour pour ce gars qui est sorti
je cours vers ce type, je le connais
Je suis le genre d'amour, il y a un type dedans
bateau il y a un type
Regarde ça
petit à petit
Dans la loi
et
nouveau
Donc